What was that? A face? Just as quickly as I
had glimpsed it, it was gone. It was cold as
death and twice as dark in here. Seriously,
I’d never been anywhere so dark. It was more
than just the absence of light, it was like
walking through thick, black water, only able
to see inches in front of my face. Things moved
slower than they should have. Every step I took,
further down towards some unknowable
destination, the darker and colder it got.
I found myself wondering, “Is this
what dying feels like? Slipping down,
further into nothingness, step by step,
through darkness that never ends?”
It was a stairway. Like Jacob’s Ladder, except
instead of up to heaven, it was a one-way trip
straight down. There was some distant, tinny
whining noise that I couldn’t quite make out,
the way things sound when you’re drowning.
I didn’t know what possibility was scarier:
That the steps just went on forever, and I’d
be walking until my bones turned to dust,
or that something would be at the
bottom, waiting for me in the dark.
The deeper I got, the more I got this sense that
the latter was true. The way you can feel yourself
being watched, or sense someone standing behind
you. That evolutionary holdover from when humans
still took part in the world of predators and
prey, and we were not the predators. Some part
of us is just built to know when true danger is
lurking nearby, or down below, patient and hungry.
I could feel its malice rising up the stairs
towards me - The way people in a skyscraper
catching fire can feel the heat coming up from
below, and know it’s already too late for them.
For the first time, my eyes came into focus,
and I made something out in the distance. When I
realized what it was - and worse, how strikingly
familiar it was - all I could do was scream.
That’s when I woke up, drenched in sweat,
and relieved to see the darkness of the
stairway replaced by bright morning light
shining in through my bedroom window.
My brother, Steve, was standing there
with a concerned look on his face.
He told me I’d been screaming in my sleep, and
asked me if I’d been having “That Dream” again.
It made me feel like an idiot, but I had to nod
and tell him, yes, it was the same one. This weird
nightmare I’d been having day after day, and
despite it almost always being the same thing,
it somehow never got any less frightening.
There was no way to even describe the profound
sense of dread I felt walking down those
stairs, and finally seeing what was waiting
for me below - Even though I could never
actually remember what it was upon waking.
Steve told me not to worry about it and tossed
some clothes onto my bed. He assured me that it
was probably just finals stress, seeing as
we were a mere few months from graduating.
I needed to be up and at ‘em today: We were
touring one of our first-choice colleges.
My brother and I had always been close.
Even if we hadn’t been fraternal twins,
I think we still would have been best friends.
All through elementary, middle, and high school,
we were practically joined at the hip, so it
only made sense that when we were getting close
to graduation, we wanted to go to the same
college. We’d be friends to the end, till
we were old men on the porch in rocking chairs.
It so happened that we were together in the end…
just not in the way I’d hoped.
The two of us arrived to check
out the potential college a few hours later.
It was a nice day out; the brightness of the
sky and the lush greenery across campus quickly
banished the bitter memories of the bad dream.
High school hadn’t exactly been a picnic for me
- I’m the nervous type if you couldn’t already
tell. Steve, who was the more outgoing and
confident one, always looked out for me.
He’d always been there whenever I was dealing
with bullies or academic stress. But at college,
I felt like I could reinvent myself, and become
the kind of person I’d always wanted to be.
As we hopped from building to building along the
tour, checking out the different facilities and
attending a few sample lectures and
seminars, I was only becoming more
confident that college would be the place for
me to finally bloom. It was perfect for me.
But, despite this college being exactly what
I’d wanted in terms of lifestyle and academic
pursuits, there was a certain stain on its
reputation. If any university is around long
enough, or any building at all for that matter,
weird incidents are bound to accumulate. Some
places have ghost or cryptid sightings,
this college had...disappearances. And
not just one or two. Six different students and
one janitor had disappeared from the campus.
The people had nothing in common except for
the fact they frequented the college. Ages,
races, genders, and majors varied
across all the missing people,
and none of them had known each other.
No notes were given, no clues discovered,
no remains ever found. A number of the cases are
even still open today. It’s a frightening thought,
that people can just drop off the face of
the earth like that and never be found.
There were over half a million
missing person cases in the US
back in 2020 alone. It’s
more common than you think.
Still, I comforted myself with
the knowledge that thousands
of new students came in and out of the
college every year, and only a handful
of disappearances. What were the chances
that something bad would ever happen to me?
Though to be fair, every person who actually
did disappear, in their last moments, thought
“What are the chances something
like this would happen to me?” too.
We were several hours into the tour when the
coffee Steve had on the way over finally caught
up with him. He needed to go. Bad. So he asked
our tour guide whether there was a bathroom
anywhere around here. She told him that he could
find one pretty easily on the ground floor of an
administrative building nearby. In the meantime,
we’d be making our way over to lecture hall 2B,
so he could simply catch up
with us there once he was done.
Steve left, and I didn’t think anything of it
at the time. I was too wrapped up in the tour.
It was only half an hour later, when we
were finishing up and preparing to leave
lecture hall 2b, that his absence from the
group suddenly became a lot more noticeable.
I started feeling nervous. He’d just gone to
the bathroom, what could be taking so long?
I ran through all the more rational explanations
in my head: Maybe there was a long line,
maybe the bathroom was out of order when he
got there and he needed to find another one,
maybe he got a little lost on the way there,
maybe he got a little lost on the way back.
There were so many perfectly rational
reasons he wasn’t with us right now.
But as the minutes dragged on, each one
felt a little less likely, and a dark
pit of dread began to form in my stomach. It
wasn’t long before I alerted the tour guide.
Naturally, she tried to calm me down, saying
how likely it was that he’d just gotten lost.
Steve was a smart kid, he was thinking of going
to this college after all so he must be smart.
There was a smattering of laughter from the
tour group. Still, she put the word out to her
fellow staff members and the search began.
Despite trying my best to avoid panicking,
the stats about all those disappearances
just kept flashing through my mind.
What if we were the unlucky ones? What
if Steve had actually disappeared,
just like the others, and I’d never see
him again? As the hours marched on and he
still wasn’t found, that was all I could
think about. I didn’t want to lose him.
I’d tried calling his cell phone
and texting him countless times,
but got no response. You can only imagine my
relief when I suddenly got a call from him.
Though when I heard the content of the
call, that relief quickly disappered.
The reception was patchy and his voice had a
strange echo to it, like he was somewhere deep
and cavernous. There was this other noise
in the background, too: This strange, tinny
whine that felt oddly familiar. I only caught
a few words from him before the call cut out.
“The door...Stay away...It keeps going...Something
down here...Don’t come looking...Oh god…”
If I was scared before, I was utterly mortified
now. I couldn’t just leave my brother in a
situation like this, no matter what he told me
to do. I had to find him somehow. I just had to.
Nobody else seemed to take it seriously, but I
somehow knew he was in the most terrible danger.
That’s when I decided to head to the one place I
believed he would be: The Administrative Building.
It was such an unremarkable little building,
hardly the kind of place where you’d expect some
terrible secret to be hiding. But dangerous things
often hide in plain sight. Things like...The Door.
It was one of the things from Steve’s
message that had stuck in my head.
“The Door.” Call it instinct, call it intuition,
call it blind dumb luck, but when I was standing
in front of an average-looking door in
that unremarkable administrative building,
I knew I was staring at the exact door that my
brother had been talking about. It radiated bad
vibes. Dark energy was practically humming
off of it. But I wouldn’t let that stop me.
Perhaps I was stupid, going in without help.
While it’s easy to criticize from the safety
of your home, it’s worth remembering: We do silly
things when we’re afraid, and I mean this was my
brother we’re talking about here. No one in the
world was more important to me than him. No one.
The second I entered the room beyond the door,
something changed. It was like stepping into
another world entirely. The air was thick and
oppressive. The floor below me and the walls
around me were ungodly cold. But most remarkable
of all was the dark. Even my phone’s flashlight at
full power barely made a dent. I don’t think I’d
ever seen anything so truly, impenetrably dark.
Outside of a certain nightmare, anyway…
That was when I finally realized where I was
standing. At the top of the stairs, those
stairs, the stairs that had been haunting my
restless sleep. A single winding stairwell
down into the void. Every part of me
wanted to run and scream and hide,
but I couldn’t. I knew that if it were me
trapped down there, Steve wouldn’t have
hesitated. He would have charged down there and
helped me. Now, I had to do the same for him.
After all, we all know that in real life,
there are no such things as monsters.
And how deep could a staircase really go, anyway?
That question was soon put to the test as
I descended down into the pit. I counted
thirteen steps each time, before reaching a
small platform. There were strange markings and
scratches on the wall, the further I descended.
Every footstep I took echoed on and on and on.
I must have been walking for a solid
fifteen minutes, traveling impossibly deep,
when I finally heard something else. I called out
Steve’s name, but quickly realized it wasn’t him.
It was a little girl, weeping, a few hundred
feet below. I couldn’t tell if she was afraid,
in pain, or both, but hearing it put ice in my
veins. What the hell was going on down there?
Had whoever taken her taken Steve,
too? What exactly was I dealing with?
These were the questions racing through my mind
as I got deeper and deeper into the belly of the
beast. Time ceased to matter as the flights went
on and on beneath me, ever descending into deeper,
colder darkness. I was literally walking
into my own nightmare, but seeing as the
only alternative was leaving my brother to
die down here, I couldn’t do anything else.
I was down countless flights of
stairs when I finally saw him.
He was a distant, pale spec, dithering
and afraid. He was a full flight down
from me. I was so happy to see him that,
at first, I didn’t even notice anything
was wrong. But as I got closer, I began to
realize that this wasn’t the Steve I knew.
The dread crept into me, spreading through
every cell like a virus. I finally knew why
I recognized it: It was the thing from my
dreams. The monster whose appearance always
brought those terrible nightmares to an end.
But what did it mean to see it in real life?
It was Steve’s face, but it seemed
larger and deathly pale. I froze,
and as the face drew closer to me, I realized
it had no irises, no pupils, no nostrils,
and no mouth. It wasn’t my brother. It looked
like a terrible, deathlike mask modeled after him.
I tried to scream as it appeared right in
front of me, just as I had in all the dreams,
but it was too late. Long, gnarled fingers
curled around my torso and crushed my ribs.
It was pain more intense than I thought
possible, and soon, even my vision went black.
“Steve...I’m sorry I couldn’t save
you. I couldn’t even save myself.”
Now go check out “SCP-087 - The
Stairwell” and “The Secret at the
Bottom of SCP-087 - EXPLAINED” for more takes
on the terrifying secret of the Stairwell!